I was looking at it cuz I wanted to ask
like what year is it since Bad Girls
when we were together and it's like
literally this year it's the 30th
Anniversary wow isn't that crazy isn't
that
crazy I mean I just like boy that went
by in a blink of an eye it did we were
bad girls back then I mean I was so
excited to be in like a western
like you know being a trick writer and
being girls that got to do what the boys
got to do right that's what I wanted to
do I just wanted to have you know oh
wait a minute what was that hold on
oh I have a surprise for you but we have
to set the atmosphere first hold on wait
a
minute oh my God
look at my little fat face oh my God not
even a little look at how young we all
look oh my
[Applause]
God okay wait a minute is there a horse
here is there a horse here or no no it's
Mary Stewart Master what no
Mary oh
[Applause]
my
hi oh my God oh my God hey hey honey how
are
you don't
worry here you sit next to Drew hi God
hi okay surpris waa why haven't you aged
one day the same thing oh my God M Stu
hi I'm like sh right now I know I was
like I'm so happy to see you guys too I
can't believe
it I was just at CVS buying your
incredible makeup Flower Beauty
beautiful and I was like this is the
best lip color ever wonder what Drew I'm
so proud of Drew she's doing so well I
was just so touched and thinking about
you and then I was uh looking through
some photos cuz um my mother passed and
I'm going through all kinds of stuff and
I found a bunch of photos you did from
our movie oh my God I remember that as
if it was yesterday that's the makeup
trailer and we would play music and we
would hang out oh I remember that so
much and we would dance and Barbara ala
we both like oh dancing literally that's
Lucan oh my God make we we like I I got
in a lot of trouble sometimes on that
film I did I was
naughty um it was so much fun and
remember Linda oakst our
producer that we were in this place for
six months and Linda was like we're
sending you to Cowboy camp and we're
going to get you into into this and she
was always fixing and solving problems
and so from her partner
yoga from her I learned like oh this is
how you run a set this is how you create
female camaraderie this is how you train
this is how you be a problem solver and
not like I don't know what to do like
from you women is literally who I am
today someone who wants to make it
happen and do it with women like
literally amazing